Lawrence I'll do whatever it takes just
come home what's coming I'm so excited
for this show I'm like you don't
understand I'm so excited for this show
yeah thank you I'm excited for people to
see it we're picking up where we left
off we're leaving no stone unturned if
you have questions they don't be
answered first episode why did you do
Lawrence so dirty what everybody people
around the world want to know why did
you do Lawrence so dirty
do you people ready do they really want
that they do want to know I'm dirty
first of all is subjective I think it
was selfish I think there are things
that haven't been explored that will be
explored in season 2 new truth will be
revealed during the BT Awards Issa fell
victim to one of the night's technical
problems ladies and gentlemen please
welcome from the hit TV show blackish
Norah Shahidi
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome the actress known for her
misadventures of an awkward black girl
retweeted one Twitter user who wrote
quote would it be Issa Rae if something
awkward didn't happen for the most part
I'm just still regular me
[Music]